Called.
According to the new legal provision,
a citizen who does not have to carry his or her ID card
is going to be held for 12 hours,
no longer for 4x12 hours at the police station.
Not carrying the DNI
involves taking you to the police station for 12 hours.
for your knowledge.
Thank you for complying
lie.
I explain everything to you
on the new identity control regulations.
Is it true that if you have no documentation
you can be held at a police station
to identify you?
Yes,
but even for 4 hours,
not 12 hours as you are saying wrongly.
He is a police officer.
After this time has passed
has to let you go without any problem.
Can you ask for my cell phone and email?
Yes,
of course.
Legislative Decree 13 38
empowers the policeman to ask you for that kind of thing,
but never,
ever.
Listen to it well.
He has to ask for your password,
never your reflection,
much less your photo gallery.
This is part of your right to your privacy.
The email
will be requested and will be checked with an email record.
Registered as stolen.
If it coincides there
you could be arrested for the crime of resectation.
and in the same case,
with your cellular equipment.
But keep in mind that never,
they can never ask you for anything on a backpack,
backpack or briefcase without a warrant.
The policeman
can only register personal objects
a detainee in flagrante delicto,
that is,
that he has been observed committing a crime.
Impossible to do so only if you were walking.
In such cases,
whenever you are arbitrarily intervened,
please record finally.
It should be noted that at about 12:00 noon
does not apply to Peruvian citizens,
is for foreign citizens only.
Please don't let the cops surprise you.
For more advice and legal tips,
follow me on this TikTok account.
I am attorney Richard Pinedo
and I am happy to help you.
Thank you very much